yes I'm Alex Rose
um today I'm going to be talking about
Apache Beam on desk portable scalable
Scientific Python also known as data
engineering for the client
I want to start with one of my favorite
quotes I'm a big fan of Mark Twain and
uh it's attributed to me that he said uh
history doesn't repeat itself but it
often rhymes
and like it was one thing that I could
one lesson I could leave you with at the
end of this talk it's this it's that
anytime you see apis that rhyme is
probably an opportunity for a greater
level of abstraction
now I don't really know much about
history but I know something about data
and right now there's a really exciting
world of Big Data everyone has a
solution to try to process and work with
big data and in many ways it kind of
seems like they all repeat each other
they have a lot of feature parity they
all maybe use direct basically graph so
these graph structures in order to
structure operations but I wouldn't say
they quite repeat here because they're
good responses to the problems they were
designed for I would say instead that
they run and maybe in the world of
solving big data problems maybe there
are greater abstractions that we create
um so that uh with with that I would
like to talk about you know three main
things in this talk uh data is seen from
dasp and beam maybe taking into account
this lesson that I just mentioned uh I
want to take a step back and look at the
big picture of you know what problems
are worth trying to solve and
um you know maybe uh data can make a big
impact for that kind of a problem space
and then I want to narrow in with you
know talking really from from the big
zoomed out view into a narrow view of
how uh being uh running on gas can be an
adequate solution to that problem
uh so first the data landscape is seen
from vast indeed I want to talk a little
bit about the history of Das it's really
funny that Matthew Rockland who you know
co-created desk is here in this
conference so you know ideas I forgive
you Matthew maybe but for instance the
history but but uh this blog post is
really excellent and as I understand it
there's kind of a huge problem in the
scientific Community uh you know not too
long ago uh where a lot of scientific
software needed to run in parallel that
scientists uh working with larger and
larger data sets uh and you know panel
Computing offered a way to make things
run faster at a larger scale and kind of
the the ecosystem of data was really
going towards math produce which I'll
talk about in a bit uh but it wasn't
really but it really LED itself to be uh
kind of like a style that science was
done maybe when the pipeline ecosystem
libraries like sci-fi and number five
um so Daft tries to answer the question
how can we use the same interfaces for
science stuff uh but take advantages you
know first of the fully utilize the
resources on a single computer like a
single machine like can we work with
data sets that are bigger than Ram that
are available on this uh through the
pool's capacity and as time has gone on
uh task is now kind of taking the python
World by storm and now we get to ask
some questions like can I work with uh
the data available when all workstations
in a cluster to work with the data
available to me that is you know outside
of the capacity of each worker in the
cluster that is available in the data as
a data center level
um you know it's good to kind of look
under the hood and see how dasp Works uh
this is kind of like the the principle
of desk that it's oriented towards task
graphs uh and it's and it doesn't appear
python or a native python way where
every time you find a function that
takes some data uh Das will actually
translate that uh kind of under the hood
into these dictionaries these mappings
between
uh
like the underlying data and lazily
evaluated functions that operate on you
know this dependency there's
dependencies you know and you very well
can translate it into like dot Biz and
you know this is kind of a tool people
often use for debugging pipelines and
tasks
um you know ultimately these are graphs
of tasks that that uh you know you can
you can use and uh you can Dash offers a
Concepts called high level graphs where
instead of just doing every single
function sometimes functions map to
multiple uh deferred functions that
depend on each other in groups
um but ultimately desk is kind of a
really lightweight set of parallelism is
based off of this concept of pass graphs
um
and now we'll take a step back and
dividend approach it's a prototypes you
know kind of created a long time ago uh
but I would like to explain it through
the problem not just like one of the
canonical problems in parallel Computing
which is word counts and uh word count
if you can solve this problem in a
distributed way you could actually solve
a huge class of problems which is why we
kind of comes up again and again and the
problem looks something like this given
a large Corpus of text
can you count the frequency of each word
so if I was writing this in Python in a
single script on a single machine it
might look like this I would iterate
through all the words in the purpose of
text and then I would basically
increment every time I saw a word and
collect it
but then I have an all question for you
it's like okay I have this now I want to
make it run in parallel how would I
translate this to run on a thousand
virtual machines
um you know took it out for you if you
go back to your first principles you
probably what we want to do is eliminate
Global State and the in parallel
Computing state is the root of all evil
and if possible we want to be using pure
functions
and is that that's my cool one approach
and kind of the this is the philosophy
of this uh style Computing where you
know this this is this Paradigm I'll
kind of uh come to the edge of the state
of map views and kind of the principles
that you uh maybe take a large
collection that's larger than any single
machine you you split a lot split up
where the data is you map it into a uh a
temp collection or to slightly different
data that lends itself for analysis the
map of these ecosystem or infrastructure
will uh Shuffle or basically kind of
like route the data to the right
instance where the processing can be
done and the reduced step usually
performs there's a high level of
fraction on any sort of aggregation that
you want to
and It ultimately then blast them to
kind of collect the results and and give
it back to the person asking the query
um so translating this word count
example kind of like this feature the
high level view of the operations would
look like you know you might have uh
animals and trying to collect how many
animals a person has you would map it
into uh
the list of names uh to just adding a
one command that that's a single
representation of a single instance of a
cat or a rabbit uh you would then
Shuffle it to the right instance there's
a reduced step that would sum them
together and then you would present that
back to the first half
and
now uh Apache B which is kind of like it
it built it was built from the
foundations of Mac produce and learned
this Paradigm Computing kind of evolved
from it where it does much more than
just map or reduce and actually just uh
has uh it's just kind of an abstract way
to represent any sort of graph of
computation so I'll talk about this a
little bit in a second but but it kind
of taking an even greater step back the
vision of being is to try to be the API
for Big Data it wants to abstract all
areas of repetition in order to build a
system where you can kind of plug in any
sort of
in a component that really is in the
life cycle of processing data so you can
run right the ideally beam is a science
being right uh you're parallel code in
any language I think uh Java python both
are supported there's always more
growing
um you can with all those languages you
can write to a single programming model
uh that's that's this graph of data and
operations
then that can be translated into any SDK
where Big Data happens like you see
familiar players like Apache spark or
high spark or Flint uh gcp offers a
service called data flow and then that
framework itself can be translated into
any sort of execution environment you
can run maybe on kubernetes or on any
sort of cloud or on gcp or AWS that's
that's kind of the vision of Apache B in
this talk or the contribution that I
recently made that are going to be
emphasizing or underscoring specifically
looks like this within just the python
ecosystem you can write programs that
exist in the beam model these get
translated or compiled to the desk bags
API which is like a particular flavor of
Das and then there's a desk Runner that
allows you to run Bean program anywhere
in the pipefide ecosystem anywhere you
can run dats
um now just to kind of you know over the
show rather than tell like what is being
talked about it very abstractly uh this
is a beam a program it has a defines a
pipeline and you can kind of configure
the pipeline to be anywhere the just a
change of arguments or a payment
arguments you can run it on uh one set
of infrastructure or another let's say
spark or fling or data flow or anything
else
um beam operates with these two
different concepts that you'd find the
graphs operations you define key
collections or parallel Collections and
P Transformations uh parallel
Transformations you know any sort of
operation if you love data and P
collections are abstractions off of
large amounts of data Peak collection
can be small it can be really really
large like in the petabyte scale or the
infinite when you're trying to deal with
streaming computations
uh created just a transformation that
turns into the beginning one and uh it
just takes data into memory and
it puts it into a p collection more or
less uh you know this what this does is
it takes a pipeline creates these two
strings puts it into the peak collection
paths and then paths would be the pipe
operator applies a map function in that
Prince and this is actually a valid
theme program if you copy and paste to
this into an environment that had beam
and you ran into it would print this
it's really just pure python is what I
want to emphasize maybe with some kind
of fun uacc syntax
um more conventional syntax so they see
pipelines are like this where instead of
having if you're just piping stuff from
one to the other
um it will really just you can just omit
the peak collections in between but
sometimes you need to use the people
actually
um to define the graphic operations
um
I kind of want to compare these two
paradigms so uh you know Das gives
documentation makes a comparison of
different types of Big Data Frameworks
and what they can do and how they're
structured and you know kind of everyone
can do embarrassingly parallel tasks
because it's where basically you're just
doing a loop and what you can do is use
them basically just combine all the
loops together and then just Farm it out
into as many seats as possible
um is not producer kind of demonstrated
that kind of introduces the one other
concept which is aggregation and adapt
is going to be unique it's a lot more
lightweight you can do full task
scheduling so you can really cooperate
with any paradigm
um maybe a core difference between uh
Das and beam is that task often is kind
of composed of graphs of tasks or these
lightweight functions that can be
deployed kind of anywhere some could be
stateful and some could be pure whereas
beam and its siblings are graphs of
operations and data
and I would basically argue uh that you
know it actually is really good to have
the first class in the thing that you're
trying to make parallel representation
or some way to describe both data and
operations the most operations in those
themselves and I argue this uh you know
we take the teenager approach because
argue that this is actually part of the
same concern that that ultimately you
know a lot of the things you want to do
to optimize the size of the code or
parallel code involve uh fitting it out
of building to the data especially data
is very large
you know here's some notes about the
benefits of adaptable approach for one
thing when you have a graph or some
compute and data you can often translate
them like it kind of that that format
that requirement allows you to translate
data into a comparisonly parallel tasks
to these evaporative things
that's a good kind of uh nudge in the
right direction it offers at the same
time really simple program abstractions
so you can focus on how you process data
as opposed to worrying about the
underlying system supports
um
an explosive graph of operations can be
automized automatically I think this is
one of the biggest benefits of the that
flow approach uh you know you with this
thing you know operator Fusion you
definitely can like combine lots of
operations when you have both uh we have
both data and uh operations taken into
account in the same level of
understanding you can globally optimize
how it's done and you can actually get
huge amounts of performance so like you
know gcp's dataflow for instance will
like calculate how many VMS that you
want to use in the first place it'll
just uh you know figure out just by the
amount of data that you're processing
how much to scale up and then it'll turn
it down and scale it down there's no
need to think about provisioning things
automatically dasc has this capability
but it's kind of hard at programming
time or configuring employment
um to know uh how to set that
um so that's that's kind of an advantage
of taking this kind of more abstract
approach and then some of the benefits
of beam in particular is that it offers
the same temperature programs that you
write for doing math processing you
automatically just makes a change in
argument or pipeline definition you can
change the world on real-time data
is like that a huge benefit
so you know I kind of want to take a few
case studies because you know I talked
about these rhyming repetition and big
data and I want to show what what a
higher level of fraction might look like
so if I describe kind of a high level
what word count is and you can see here
kind of the the parts board count of
represented in heistmark another big
data framework that you get all the
words in a large Corpus and lines if you
split them then you map them to tokens
uh the key and a single value you reduce
them by summing all the values across
the key after a shuffle step and then
you can output it similarly in Apache
Flink you do something really similar
the syntax is a bit different but It
ultimately is kind of the same high
level python where you group and then
you reduce
uh you know buy a key and then you can
output that into a file or to the thing
to a console
and uh this is what this is the a common
abstraction that you can create for
those those two programs that rhyme that
offer almost the same thing
um where uh it's in veeam it's it's uh
you basically extract all the words we
get a collection of parallel collection
of words
um you map the tokens and then you
combine the library key basically is a
or it's a composite function basically
it's an aggregation of a lot of decimal
operations
and my question for the audience my
question is why can't desk uh join all
these other players you know dasque
itself offers this interface called bags
bags if you look at it you squint they
actually requirements the same thing as
parallel Collections and all these other
distributed data structures and other
Frameworks this is an example of Dash
Bag code it's not word count but it's
something doing something very similar
and yeah that's the data flow model it
seems like you could probably join with
the rest and we offer this type of
Paradigm in the pipeline ecosystem uh
but a question I have is why build this
what problem does it solve you know I
feel like a lot of stuff might be really
interesting to do uh in software
engineering that we get really excited
about Solutions It's always important to
kind of feel like and in uh knowing what
to build you have to ask yourself uh not
just what is it good to build but what
problem does it solve and uh why you
know that it always is important to
ground uh the technical direction to
make in kind of the business or a larger
impacts
I'd like to take a step back and think
more broadly about kind of why we do
data work and uh maybe the very big
picture problem that I would like to
talk about is how can software
engineering help address the climate
crisis the climate crisis is the largest
challenge of our time uh and I would say
like maybe many people in this room here
being data practitioners uh probably
already know that a lot of the core
problems involved in climate full
climate adaptation and mitigation
fundamentally are information problems
you can have better power grids if you
knew more weather information if we
could be able to predict the weather or
if we were able to optimize the flow of
electricity
um if we can make more informed
decisions we could probably ensure
houses better you know a lot of these
fundamental challenges in climate change
really are informational challenges
um just as an aside as you have those
introduced I work in private and weather
research I work on weather data in
particular I just want to talk a little
bit about within the big scope of trying
to address climate change let's look at
the climate as a data more directly and
the data that makes up climate often is
weather data weather data is the
original Big Data I would actually say
um you know like traditionally Earth
observations in the produce at such a
rapid rate that we've just thrown them
away
uh because they're not the compute
infrastructure because long-term because
it's based or you know mathematical or
compute-based solutions to predict the
weather
um we've just not had the ability to
scale up to the challenge Earth data is
you know I would say astronomically
large I feel like I don't know maybe
what was it pun intended
uh you know what another thing just a
total aside to uh weather prediction as
a problem as uh followed the history of
advances in Computing you know if you
look right here kind of the uh when
computers were people they thought of
like making a physical building it was a
globe and having people in the rooms to
cover different regions enhanced
numerical populations passing with
papers uh to try to do things like
predict the weather you know and
basically the Paradigm of numerical
weather prediction was basically
continued with that where we automated
as much of it as possible but if you
look at even like the evine women
architecture the definition of any app
and like the CPU infrastructure that we
have
um you know created by Bobby Womack I
think he was working on Los Alamos was
trying to stimulate or predict the
leather
um you know the definition of Chaos
Theory you don't have a picture here but
cast Theory but chaotic systems and like
mathematics really uh the math for
convection was really trying to scale up
why we can't use probabilistic
approaches to predict the weather a
really fascinating domain in computers
um
and uh one thing I would like to
underscore uh like because what is
history is so old and client history is
so old right now even today weather data
is incredibly painful to work with there
are all these formats with kind of
invested me like 80s uh that exist today
that really require that require you to
download data locally and process it and
basically designed for the HTC systems
uh like I performs computer
supercomputers where um you basically
have these large file systems and they
all kind of run like batch jobs on those
systems it's not really modeled up for
options like the modern infrastructure
compute today which is cloud computing
this is a particular meter logical
institution in Europe there's
multi-government uh Institute easy to be
up here at least medium range forecasts
I would say like my short tldr
description to them is they have the
best weather models in the world and
their the quality of their weather
models are directly proportional how
hard they are to access and to
illustrate that
um
this is a video
like to request let's say a terabyte of
that or a gigabyte I think this is a 75
gigabyte limit of something one of their
apis you trigger an API request it puts
you in a global queue for the entire
world uh or you know people have access
to this and then it basically triggers a
robot arm to access a tape drive to then
get the thing beaten to disk and then
send it over a network so there's
basically a huge amount
opportunity to make
uh working with weather data a lot
better
um
and uh you know looking back at on the
big picture problem uh you know right
now it's cop 27 a year ago this top 26
this is the leading of the biggest
conference for all world leaders and
people working climate change to um come
together and see how we can all come
together and we'll work out a solution
uh uh you know Representatives at Google
uh you know one last year basically
talking to people kind of came to the
idea that uh there's kind of a huge need
for a global data Commons that that data
should be able to be uh very accessible
and easy to access uh and use modern
compute infrastructure and it's not just
a matter of then we can build better
weather models and do better data
science it's also a matter of
information Equity that uh kind of like
the keynote speaker from from uh
yesterday's talk that everyone should be
able to do science everyone should be
able to have access to critical weather
information which is uh really
invaluable creating decisions and all
that faster to life
um so uh you know there's a huge need to
the problem I guess the inclusion is
like you know if it can come together
what can software Engineers do they
probably can uh you know create open
science and create that data Commons uh
to make uh this this piece of
information so unable to climate into
many things
um uh highly accessible
you know so maybe we can take a deep
breath that was kind of a really big big
picture I want to narrow in on a few
things happening now that
kind of make good progress in this space
um so uh there's this project I think
mentioned elsewhere at this conference
called Pangea Forge
um you know just to give an interaction
with tangioforge how many people here
have uh heard of Honda Forge by showing
hands
okay uh so yeah for the people who
haven't raised their hands uh how many
here know what Anaconda is or conda
based condo install cool so condos this
is package manager uh it use it's used
to install scientific software Honda
Forge is this open source Community like
you have
uh that months basically the principles
have any science any two scientists can
uh write reusable codes to compile
scientific software often the python
ecosystem but not only
um and upload it to a community
controlled and mediated by repository
something called the feedstock and then
everyone that problem is then solved you
know people don't have to worry about
getting their environment right in order
to do science and like uh you know
product scientific software that's the
basic condo Forge and I think it's been
really hugely successful you know I
think like Mumba for instance the
package manager that like defaults to
conduct forward as opposed to the
default channel in Honda uh can geoforge
is trying to be the condo force your
data sets it is focused on climate
science data trying to make it um
basically solve the problems that I
mentioned taking while the data easy to
work with one of the ways that they're
trying to make them better is creating a
catalog is by changing it to a moderate
compute Paradigm through Cloud
optimization Cloud optimization
basically means uh you know we have
totally different uh system of compute
that was designed and presented
Computing for super super Computing
range that we see we have these large
file systems now we have kind of these
object Stores
um and uh what's really great about is
you can pay only for you you that's
highly available and with libraries in
the pipeline ecosystem especially like
Das and X-ray and others like it you can
kind of just load in what you need just
when you need it and then operate on it
um and uh in general Cloud optimization
kind of shifts away from the traditional
Paradigm of all these data sets where
we're not working like downloading to
our local machines processing and then
moving it back up it's much more akin to
like uh moving code to data that you see
also in like
Style
of a feeding
um I do want to caution you though uh
you know just as a disclosure I'm a
contributor to tangio forge like my team
in research is working with them quite a
bit for various data sets
um and I also want to say that this
project is very early days kind of being
on uh had you affords like being on
Honda when people are just trying to
give you the pitch about it and you're
like we have Anaconda we haven't hit you
know
um that's my big caution
um so what's it like to contribute a
recipe just like Honda Porsche has
recipes so do Pangea porridge and this
is a you know actual live recipe for
this data set this is a data set from
NOAA the climatology is just an average
for time and year or like hour there's
been windows and time but it's basically
like an average uh of climate variables
never on the globe this is a
precipitation in climatology
um and this is what it's like so we have
this data set uh hosted by NOAA which is
an American Eagle Optical institution
um this python script iterates through
you know the 20 or 30 years of data this
is the X-ray Czar recipe this converts
it from using the Czar x-ray Library
into a cloud office format called Czar
which I'll demo in a little bit and then
through its infrastructure it's Bakery
you get this basically like pandas data
frame it's like a little different than
that that you can work within a Jupiter
elbow and kind of like using gas under
the hood you can um
yeah just stream the data as you need it
and do all kinds of computation at a
whole new scale in a way more to
optimized way so like from this
interface you can work with terabytes if
not petabytes of data as python data
frames or x-ray data sets
um I have a small demo uh
it is not the largest data set of scenes
are I you know personally processed uh
something a bit bigger but this is out
of the pan geoforce catalog
uh you basically can copy
code like this
sorry it's really hard to see if I paste
it into a locally run jupyter notebook
and run it
I get this data frame and let's see how
big this is
like getting my origin back to
two rooms this is like a two terabyte
data set that I can treat as uh just
like a lightweight data frame and a
local notebook
um and if this can make uh climate and
weather data much more democratized
um
okay
uh so this is the overall structure of
Pantene Forge this is like it's it's
architecture and how it operates and I
would say um you're not going too into
detail right now I would say that Pangea
Forge as a system has a few core
challenges
uh it one has the challenge of
scalability the compute must scale to
earth-sized data this is data that often
operates in the like hundreds of
terabytes to petabytes to hundreds of
petabyte scale
um event that needs to be portable if
you're trying to create a like something
like a data Commons and try to make
something that promotes open science it
has to be able to run everywhere so
bakeries need to run on all Cloud
infrastructures as well as high
performance compute systems as well as
locally for introspection and any other
place you can really imagine and uh
recipes the the system that we use to
describe transformations of data needs
to be highly extensible
um the rest of the API must be able to
adapt to any type of processing or data
source
um so let's take a look right now at how
can you afford to solve these problems
today so this these uh problem kind of
came up as issues that we saw over and
over again and trying to make team can't
do afford to work against sister
projects
um you know this is this is the
underlying code like kind of the code
that I showed before to create that data
set I just demoed look something like
this you have uh and x-rays are recipe
compiler you have a compiler that has
steps of Transformations and this is the
abstraction for it basically is like
functions uh that say whether or not
they can take in data and it's really
interesting this looks like a recipe
defining graphs of operations of data
and if you look a little bit more about
what a recipe is it looks like
these get compiled into executors where
data is run
this API runs that arrives with B
uh
and you know what we're starting to do
is take a new direction for Pangea Forge
is that we're adopting a big data
compiler instead of becoming one and
that Das support uh is an important
piece of that that component of Dash
support desk itself Bridges the gap
between uh this this big data
engineering framework and a lot of the
infrastructure where science is run Das
is a critical component like many uh you
know even old school weather
institutions or let's say scientific
institutions uh use desk as their core
set of infrastructure for maintaining
our scheduling high performance compute
software just being able to for me to
support Das actually means that we have
a key requirement in development which
is uh uh two portabilities everywhere
where these you know status offerings to
run and the last uh what's really great
about it is offers potential which they
had no plan for extensible API put into
handling real time to our streaming data
and climate Sciences
um talking about Beam on Das the project
status is still very experimental uh the
first change has landed in the Apache
project in me you can I don't know what
literally released maybe where it's less
experimental uh but uh there it is
possible to use dap you write being
programs in and have them run on vast
infrastructure to kind of show you the
value of the idea of you could abstract
apis that rhyme the core thing that
enables us to bridge the beam
programming model into the dash one is
this like 20 or so lines of code where
like you know dasp itself is very beam
is a graph a data flow graph of data and
operations and they kind of end up
looking like this and we just directly
can translate using something called the
visitor pattern it's like a solid you
know a data 4 software design pattern
but a basically to iterate through a
graph really
maybe try to visit every node and then
just kind of directly just the high
level of the description of what this is
is you can kind of just translate uh
Bean graphs into Dash graphs and uh the
rest of this stuff is maybe uh details
to make it run and execute uh kind of in
the environment
and uh I can you know offer a
demonstration people looks really
curious I have like on my local machine
with the latest change into uh the
Apache project the ability to run tangio
Ford recipes in uh BFD on Dax
um yeah and uh you know a question that
I feel like is really exciting about
this area of work is uh can be even able
open science at scale there are other
projects happening at Google research by
mainly by my colleague a step employer
who wrote the library um library and
x-ray with others he's created this
project called x-ray mean and uh kind of
like this is a perfect marriage between
uh beam and desk and on the other side
um all these projects kind of work
together but you know let's see how a
large data set an x-ray data set which
is a multi-dimensional you know highly
dimensional data set to be prescribed
and weather the dasp approach just kind
of split them into small amount of
chunks
uh and then kind of stream in the tasks
into the available resources you have
the X-ray meme approach is to split them
up kind of in this map reduce pair line
to small amounts of chunks so that you
can use this new uh this other style of
computing to
um you know really highly scalable and
automatically processed
so this is for instance a b program in
an example in this this repository and
that what it does is it it basically
call this one function after splitting
up all the data and what it does is it
calculates climatology if you're another
data set called verify and again a
climatology is kind of like an average
of the way it's letter climatology and
data scientists is that um like your
machine model is good if you um can be
50 if you're doing a binary
classification because if you're less
than 50 percent it's to the opposite
whatever the model says uh the average
of that in climate and weather is uh you
take the average per of the weather of
the season of that time of year
um if you can predict something better
than that then you agree
and climatology enables that it also is
a good way to measure climate
climate um
you know I'm happy to talk about Lessons
Learned you don't have a bit of time for
that I would say that in the ultimate
lesson that I would like to leave you
with is that anytime you see uh
repetition that they're not necessarily
structures or apis that repeat they're
just rhyming and rhyming is actually a
really good sign it shows you that
there's an opportunity for a higher
level of attraction and then the lessons
that I learned on this project is that
it's not necessarily uh it's not
necessarily the worst thing to um
like build things then throw them away
and find something better because you
gained a better understanding of the
problem and a better
uh you even though you might reuse the
code you gain information
with that thank you so much uh coming to
my talk and answer any questions if
you'd like to get involved to learn more
uh here are some repos that I touched
upon I'm a contributors to the top two
and I'm a maintainer of the bottom two
um and yeah thank you so much
thank you
[Music]
foreign
yeah sure um
yeah uh you know ecmwf has I mean at
least there are meteorological
institution that have been around for a
very long time there's intergovernmental
like conglomerate if they need that
offices in Europe and uh I think this is
just kind of true really it's not unique
to them but like whether it's been
around for a long time we've been really
involved in early Computing uh that like
they just are on an infrastructure for
like long-term Stories the best
available at the time when they were
related to store masses amounts of data
or tapes and it's really hard but it's
going to Legacy system especially data
that's so expensive uh they they have
like you know maybe uh 40 or 50 years of
you know like I don't know like five
petabytes or maybe like 100 petabytes of
data for a real-time forecasts and
historical other things that they're all
on tape drives and it's huge projects to
modernize them and a lot of the the
investment that they have is in making
the Next Generation weather models is
supposed to
structure but yeah that is a huge
challenge kind of anyone who's like a
taxi on the world's weather actually um
this this code-based weather tools is
like a I wrote a meme pipeline myself to
try to make downloading data from ecmw
better it was like needed out of a
custom code or script that I use uh
being for
um yeah that doesn't answer your
question of how to go more into detail
oh there's a school uh company called
educlip and there is AI to
um every single frame of the video like
tag it with like tags that applied to
things that appear or are mentioned in
that frame
um and so like AI is going to be able to
search in a video
um for like if you want like you have a
question like oh when in this video like
did they mention this or when like did
this appear in this video and you have
like like that from that ECM you know
like um and you want to search up a
whole video database um like an AI is
going to be able to like and they're
also going to have like AI That's like
multi of the year so like
I'll be able to be uh compatible with
the take format
um of like that data like that being
secure on tape
um but I really like searching video to
find like really like searching Google
like because there's a good video and
that's pretty cool it's cool the idea
maybe maybe so you're looking to the how
to get index for historical weather yeah
I think there's a huge amount of
opportunities we can build on top of
something uh we just have the underlying
data just in a more a project a format
that lends itself for analysis in the
first place all kinds of things to build
um they're really important to get into
these these Cloud advice format just
make the support all the kind of really
cool AI that we can do
um but yeah you know I think the storage
medium is a fundamental Challenge and
projects in non-focus for supporting
projects for instance like Czar uh which
which are useful kind of in multiple
domains of science but also especially
climate and weather uh but they can
really enable that I mean these data
sets are the primary focus of a
pangeophoric for instance is thought of
placing data
so Quantum computing computers oh sorry
do you mind if I take another question
yes
um so I I just want to say thank you for
your talk because oftentimes I've heard
talks around dots especially if
uh curating if you were applying it on
much larger data sets of synthetic
terabyte size is is really meaningful so
when if I were to visit your Apache
mean uh repository would I be able to
find like good examples
and like implemented book together and
like translated being
for Basketball Association yeah I guess
hey I want to be I only should have been
clear a bit of my talk that uh the
infrastructure we used for for these
size of data sets were primarily a gcp's
data flow okay and ask is is something
that is necessary for the future of the
NGO board project
uh and uh again it is very experimental
like a lot of the stuff like you know
developed recently as recently as last
week and I really want to talk about
like uh just the kind of idea of the
vision of being that it also can include
tasks um but I think what is really cool
about let's say you wanted to start a
project you're not really sure what
infrastructure to use you want to be
able to like make sure that you can have
something you can make clean for a long
time and I can uh you know like be be
deployed elsewhere in an infrastructure
that works you can be like well I have
some desk infrastructure locally at
coiled uh you know setup I'll write this
beam Pipeline and I'll run a dash and
then later okay like now I'm working on
with like lots of user data that
actually can collected or Earth data or
whatever it is I need something with a
little more oomph and you can switch to
other services and other infrastructures
so I think that that's kind of a
you know I I certainly emphasize that
more on my top
yeah
uh yeah I'm not very familiar with that
I'm more like a spark user and uh
working with your spatial data has been
like
donated so
computation so if you can talk more
about
um what kind of conversations are you
running
what support me well if you are here in
spark and you want to
um do a lot of like nerve science I
actually highly recommend this Library
x-ray theme if you have infrastructure
at your work or wherever you do you know
spark jobs for geospatial data uh you
basically can reuse all that to keep it
the same whatever that the connectors
that have the data and then if you're
programming in Python you can use
basically like a lot of libraries or
working with faster data this also is a
I guess like you know I talked a lot
about beam but I haven't really talked
about the library I'm alluded to it
x-ray x-ray is like it's a library for
kind of labeled multi-dimensional arrays
like a pandas data frame is kind of like
in 2D an x-ray you have this higher
dimensional sense of data so
so I like maybe I've been playing around
with it and kind of show a demo so this
Czar data set
is an x-ray data set
so like this is one variable it's going
to be a very good example of like in
theory um I have a set of coordinates
this is an advances are axes uh which
process data and then I could have like
you know hundreds go on like variables
that fit along those coordinates and
other metadata I also have attributes
where I can label kind of other metadata
about the data set and um you know I
think this is a really perfect tool to
analyze geospatial data and it really
was designed for that problem in mind
although offering some kind of end
domain of Science and then focused for a
project
um you know you know full disclosure of
you know my colleague
you know work works on this I already
you know created this I don't know but
anyway I think this plus theme like
x-ray mean could be a really great
solution for you for um you're doing
distributed uh
yes quickly uh working with xrv instead
of working with key collection if you're
working with exclusions collections
yeah that's a good question so uh x-ray
beam the question was like why we use
x-ray theme versus Pay collections no no
it's you know I completely experience
the changes
represent
s
right now your collection
or whatever it's called right
now yeah that's the Big Valley next
grade being the key collections can be
talking about these really high
dimensional tensors
it offers really clean interface to work
with it so yeah I haven't talked to you
before
thank you